nous avons signé un protocole de fin de
conflit qui conserve une hausse à 49 et
6 ou 3 points qu'il n'y ait pas aussi
registre qu'il n'y ait pas de
représailles
qu'ont fait degrés et qu'il y ait
aujourd'hui un organisme soit la rade
soit l'association des médiateurs qui
interviennent au niveau de l'institution
pour accompagner les agents dans les
conditions de travail et également à
accompagner le personnel puisque on ne
sort pas de fin de semaine de grève sans
ça puisque j'ai laissé
enfin il roi protocole qui sera un
comité paritaire pardon qui sera réunie
faut s'assurer de la mise en oeuvre du
protocole du personnel du partenaire n'a
pas été en grève
il faut le répéter il s'agit d'une
poignée de riz ce qu'ils avaient des
revendications qu au départ d'ordre
politique essentiellement politique
puisque il demandait ni plus ni moins
que l'éviction du président du pâtre est
également la suppression l'annulation de
du licenciement du dgs or ces deux
revendications disparu de manière à ce
qu effectivement on puisse arriver à son
tour